with the fall of the infamous rogue
agent Erin keener a new line of rogue
agents were put into action to fulfill
what he calls his legacy with the first
manhunt now concluded what exactly were
they trying to achieve
[Music]
[Music]
Moli Henderson callsign Jupiter was
recruited by the division after proving
herself in the private sector as a
security consultant leaning on a
four-year military background
Jupiter excelled in combat and physical
training exercises however she was noted
as a potential risk due to her past
involvement and militant activism she
had been part of a group that was later
involved in the kidnapping and assault
of a prominent business executive
nevertheless nothing could ever be tied
to her as she claimed to have left the
group by the time of the incident and
all psychological evaluations supported
this claim Jupiter was activated as part
of the divisions first wave and it was
at this time that she first me at Aaron
Tina her status was changed to rogue
after an incident in the New York
quarantine zone where two jtf officers
were killed Jupiter has since been
linked to the murders of at least 15 jtf
officers sometime after this Keane
returned to New York he approached
Jupiter and had her establish a team for
a future attack that will be carried out
in Washington DC waiting for you and
your team in Jamaica Bay are you sure
you can't take the lead on this mission
your team is perfect you work well
together and I know I can trust you to
handle things in Washington really wish
you were coming with us I can't leave
New York now there's too much at stake
besides my team didn't really play well
with others the fair still could use
more bodies just in case things go
sideways don't worry I'm gonna let you
go without backup Khan was left you a
present you didn't like it just don't
forget to feed them
one of the first agents that Jupiter got
in contact with was Rhine Chang mutual
friends thought we might be able to help
each other out
this is a clear channel secure enough
what's your name you want to call sign
for this op same smart went to the
planetarium last week always been
partial to mercury high mercury names
Jupiter nice to meet you
there's a true you're working with the
corners I've got access but Connolly
Uranus is their real leader Mars brought
us together they're efficient if I had a
team like that here we could have
eradicated the outcast in a couple of
weeks that's the goal
mercury was recruited by the division
from the military after earning a Silver
Star in Afghanistan he left the military
and became a marketing manager for a
technical equipment company mercury was
activated as part of the division second
wave but was marked as rogue after
reportedly torturing and executing
prisoners he has been described as
intelligent in calculating with the
tendency for violent outbursts peer
reviews Wrigley described him as being a
bit difficult to work with
Billy Ron mercury can be heard arguing
with Kelso regarding the loading of
supplies into a cargo plane ready for
transport this is a mistake
the shipment goes out tonight we need
this gear we have enough supplies we're
just moving the surplus if the hyenas
are the true sons find out about this
stockpile yes the true sons come for us
we'll need these weapons to defend
ourselves you're a good agent Ryan but I
need you to help me out and just finish
the job we don't have time to argue
about this the plane is already on its
way
mercury felt these supplies will be
bitter used to help in the fight against
the true sons and the hyenas
the cargo plane in question would later
crash onto Roosevelt Island not long
after this incident mercury was marked
as road
Chadwicks Brandon callsign Neptune was a
flight engineer at the time of
recruitment and was activated as part of
the divisions first wave his job was to
contain the civil unrest in the early
days and to secure the Midtown
quarantine zone
not long after activation he ran into
another agent called Mike the two men
started working together as a team
forming a tight bond during his time
with the shd Neptune set up a lot of the
critical infrastructure at the base of
operations including a set of backup
generators that could guarantee stable
power and communications however when
the retreat was called in the quarantine
zone Neptune and Mike will have
surrounded by rioters and no JTF to
support them while under heavy fire
Mike was gunned down while neptune only
just managed to escape dismayed by the
loss of his partner and close friend
Neptune held a grudge towards the JTF he
went on to sabotage the generators that
he helped build in the base of
operations and turned killing 8jt of
staff members and injuring 23 more after
that nip soon disappeared reporting from
midtown Manhattan final midtown sitrep
the JTF left us behind we lost I don't
know how many ages because of it people
who relied on the JT of support but
never got it you were supposed to tackle
this together but when this [ __ ] hit the
fan it was clear we were on our own Mike
died because of them we ran into each
other when we first got activated you
work well together I wasn't there for
him no one was and now I'll never see
him again we're not going to forget this
neptune down and reached out to them
they're looking for you
let them come do you think you can
handle it want a full squad storms in
and surrounds you I'm not going down
without a fight
I'll take some of them with me you die
they win I don't give a [ __ ] anymore
this world can get [ __ ] for all I care
I know you're hurting
I'll leave you with your grief if you're
still alive and want to do something you
know where to find me
we can [ __ ] the world together initially
Nixon refused but after had been given a
little more time to mourn and think over
it he got back in contact with Jupiter
Lucy Anders codenamed Venus was a first
wave division agent whose status changed
to rogue after she abandoned the mission
disappearing for six weeks
investigations revealed that she had
established her own safehouse and was
directly undermining the JTF s-- work by
claiming critical drops and suppliers
destined for a JTF operations base later
on three division agents were dispatched
to retrieve the stolen supplies they
managed to locate Venus but two of the
agents were killed and the third was
seriously injured this agent was able to
survive and record an eyewitness account
of the incident
marry masters aka
satin was an attorney before she was
recruited by the division she was part
of the first wave that was released
after the dollar flew first struck
however like many before her she turned
rogue not long after reports state that
she shot down an extraction helicopter
in dark zone West in Washington DC
killing two JTF pilots in a division
agent for psychological evaluations
indicates signs of trust issues and a
lack of confidence in others
mercury this is Jupiter come in this is
mercury we're set moving out tonight
should be in your solar system in a
couple of days what code we're coming to
your neck of the woods should be there
in a couple of days oh why didn't you
just say that we all set yeah black tusk
invaded the island but local agents
cleared though doesn't appear a cargo
has been discovered racist LLL be good
to go
great you send me the coordinates
Marisa's network up and running yet
local test runs but not system-wide you
should still be able to send direct
messages great anything special if
you're in jails correct we should have
everything we need from the crash Uranus
is working on some new prototypes specs
are saved on the network hopefully we'll
be able to test some of them once we get
to Roosevelt looking forward to it
Jupiter's team we're preparing for the
mission supplies have been stockpiled
and were being loaded into the safe
house one of these included a rid
package from Erik Gina Jupiter we've got
a care package from tainer a red packet
yes art what do you want me to do with
it get rid of it I don't want anything
to do with that you sure you saw what it
could do at City Hall this is the
leverage Keenan was talking about this
isn't some kind of silver bullet Saturn
he's a [ __ ] body weapon we're doing
this to eradicate a virus not spread
something even more dangerous
of course you're right I'll destroy it
just be careful
I don't wanna find out you drafted and
killed the whole team don't worry I've
got this under control yeah that's what
they all say until they don't
this package contained kinas new super
virus that have been developed by
training Co but Jupiter wanted nothing
to do with us regardless of what Keener
had in mind
Jupiter's mission was still the same to
remove the virus to do with the JTF and
the government were incapable of doing
themselves she wasn't going to replace
the dollar flew with an even more deadly
virus before Jupiter's team could roll
out she needed to ensure that their
communications and logistics would be
robust she needed someone to stay behind
and hold the fort why don't we leave I
need you to stay back on this one you're
kidding look Saturn you know I trust you
yeah you're the best agent I've got
Venus can be a little unpredictable and
Neptune's barely keeping it together can
you blame them no but that right there
is why I need you here you care about
people I need you to make sure the
operation is secure fine
what do you need maintain the safe house
clip comms open in case we need anything
you take care of Eclipse yeah
found a way to neutralize the dispersal
mechanism put in a hole blew it up and
bury the evidence I knew I could count
on you next mission you're with me in
the field
Jupiter couldn't trust Venus or Neptune
to stay on track
Saturn was most reliable option she had
all right I know you're calling these
guys I know you answered to her but
until this operation is over your answer
to me and my crew I don't have any
problems we have a long journey and a
hard road ahead of us
but if we do this if we get this right
we will be that much closer to
eradicating the disease once and for all
we're multiple reports of experiments
trying to weaponize the virus being
carried out with the blood of
asymptomatic carriers we need to
eliminate this threat we're going to
locate the lab samples and these
carriers to make sure the green poison
is destroyed once and for all the
mission was to eradicate the green
poison reports of experiments in within
izing MIT no to focus on locating labs
samples and carriers of the virus and
putting into it once and for all but
with the introduction of the cleanest to
the team Jupiter found herself in an
argument with Venus she expressed it
concerns about working with the
phonetics and that she didn't trust
their intentions in particular Venus was
having trouble with a leader of cleaning
back up Buckley
I can't work with Buchanan or Baker or
whatever the hell that guy's name is you
mean Barkley
I can't understand anything he says in
that stupid [ __ ] mask what's the
problem he doesn't respect me his team
doesn't respect me if they don't listen
to me they're gonna get us all killed
you're exaggerating I'm not Jupiter
come on you know me look I can talk to
him but it's not gonna make him respect
you you want him to respect you take
care of it yourself
oh I'll take care of it I just needed
permission
Jupiter told her that they needed the
backup and that she needed to find a way
of working with them or that maybe she
just wasn't suitable for the job at hand
so Venus took it upon herself to rather
than reason with the guy to instead
shoot him what Barkley's dead you told
me to take care of it so what took care
of it
I meant talk to him not shoot him in the
head I did talk to him he yelled at me
everyt for his axe my response was
measured and appropriate huh is that
true
true enough and now his team listens to
me so see I took care of it
you didn't take care of it you were
supposed to gain their respect not the
fear Venus they listen to you now
because they're afraid of you bitter
soon if they aren't afraid you messed up
I thought you were better than this
mercury good to me interpreter that was
a trip
fine couple of rough patches had to put
out a couple of fires you know the usual
everything said at the docks we should
be good supplies are a little low need
to send a couple of strike teams out for
food water and weapons but we've got
plenty of space and the boys are looking
for fuel you gave me a list of what you
need and I can help you make those
strike teams you're good I'm efficient
Jupiter's team was now in DC mercury
initiated his attack on multiple sites
including the capital building Lincoln
Memorial Space Administration HQ and Air
and Space Museum capturing a number of
the control points in between while
nipson focused on the western side of DC
Venus made moves in northeastern DC
capturing multiple sites of value in
downtown East Federal Triangle and
judiciary square while set and continued
to hold down the safe house in New York
one by one the division was able to
locate the rogue agents in DC including
settings whereabouts and lower Manhattan
well though they put up a strong fight
the division agents were quickly able to
eliminate them while this was happening
Jupiter was still running point on the
main mission while o team was being
hunted down and killed by the division
Jupiter was on Roosevelt Island
she was securing a newly developed EMP
technology from a cargo plane that had
crashed this some time ago
combined with Vivian Connolly's
technology these new EMP jammers were
able to neutralize all non rogue shd
tech and completely removed an agent's
armor Jupiter's goal was to capture the
stick get it operational and ship it out
to rogue agents nationwide this would
[ __ ] the remaining shd agents around
the country the purpose of the team of
agents and the accompany cleaners was to
distract the division or she prepared
Roosevelt Island
however the division reacted faster than
Jupiter was prepared for the agents
managed to overwhelm the rogues and push
the cleaners back to the island where
Jupiter was forced to make a last stand
she ordered the cleaners to utilize all
available EMP jammers to put a stop to
the fast approaching agents but it was
too late the division pushed through the
defense's destroying the EMP s and found
themselves face-to-face with Jupiter and
eventually after a long battle and
embarrassingly longer than I'd like to
admit
the agents put a stop to her plants
killing her in the process
[Music]
and thus about sums up the first stage
in kinas so-called legacy I by no means
think that this is a last that we'll see
as upcoming seasons open up but I did
enjoy the small amount of story this is
added especially how it showed that they
didn't all buy into kinas extreme
methods with his introduction of a new
and improved virus this also fit into
something that would be wondering about
since early on after release of the game
busy I know
we found something kind of strange
you're gonna have to be more specific
yeah it's like a room down here the
escape tunnel yeah I thought no not that
it's a room with my guys and I was
sterilizing burned some altar looking
things and we accidentally opened this
room you watch yeah it's like some kind
of shrine or something big-ass bird
statue looks kind of like an owl the
name morovian mean anything to you I'll
be right there it doesn't give us
anything to work with but it certainly
shows that there's more to the story
hopefully to be expanded on in future
editions anyway I hope you've enjoyed
this story time within Gian I'll catch
in the next one Cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]